When I was a kid,
I can go through them a math book in a
week,
so I'm going to see about chop.
They got down there.
What job?
Stockbroker
stop.
Fuck yeah,
not an astronaut.
I listened to what Jim Valvano said.
21 years.
The most poignant seven words ever
uttered in any speech anywhere.
Don't give up.
Don't ever give up.
Those great people didn't.
So I now have a responsibility to also
not ever give up.
I'm not special.
I just listened to what the man said.
But I tell you,
there is some times in life where you
fall down.
I feel like you don't have the swing to
get that gun.
I will try 100 times to get up any five
fail 100 times.
If I fail and I give up,
do you think that I'm ever going to get
up?
No.
If I fail,
I try again and again and again for as
long as I try it this way,
say change to be getting up
when the secret is inactive it up.
Everybody who's done something great,
they weren't,
that wasn't resiliency.
They have the ability to bounce back all
the grades.
They didn't wait,
wait,
stay on course guarantee.
You cannot pass it.
If you quit,
I guarantee he's going to fail,
but you don't know what's going to
happen if you keep going.
I'm prejudice.
I feel pain.
I heard I opened my eyes.
I create victory,
but do not give up.
I feel no fear.
I fear no man.
I create a conqueror.
I hold the power.
Make a choice.
Just decide what is going to be,
who you're going to be,
how you're going to do it.
Just decide and then from that point,
the universe is going to get out your
way.
We can have another bad year.
You've got to get to the point where
enough is enough.
You much easier to come up with excuses
why you can't do it.
If you do what is easy,
your life will be hard.
If you do want to say is complain about
your situation,
your circumstances,
surrender and give up on your dreams,
become depressed,
bitter and angry.
Anybody can do that.
If you do what is easy,
your life will be,
oh,
what have you do?
What is hard?
Coming back again and again and again.
Get up dressed every day.
Take Life.
Oh,
taking life by the collar.
You say,
yes,
I will do it.
I can do this.
And you've said yourself,
I'm willing to face the know.
I'm willing to,
people laugh at me.
I'm willing to cut this out.
I'm willing to make this happen.
It's possible.
It's necessary.
It's hard,
it's worth it.
Or I'm going to do whatever it takes.
I can do it.
If anybody's ever done at any point in
time and history,
then what's possible for one,
it's possible for me and I'm going to do
it.
And if you do that over and over and
over again,
yeah,
your life will be easy.
Okay?
Some is going to be your first day if
you'd like to work here as a broker.
But you like that Chris?
Yes,
sir.
Yeah.